hello everyone and welcome to a
remarkable chest position that I
stumbled upon while browsing Twitter as
I usually do it was posted on Twitter by
an account called Elite Minds so if you
guys want to follow them they might drop
some interesting content in the future
as well uh but this one uh here is very
very special it's uh sort of a
composition it's uh it says that it's
from an actual game it says that it's
from a game uh turitsky versus walked in
1896 although it's very hard to
corroborate that because uh the
composition was made by a very well
known composer endgame composer Alexa
Alexander this is the the gentleman I'm
talking about and uh most of his notes
were destroyed during the siege of
Leningrad during the World War II and
um there's just uh not not all that much
left but he does have uh a lot of these
end game studies uh published and
although we don't know if it was from an
actual game and we do not not have the
moves that lead to this position the
position is it itself is quite
remarkable now in the composition says
that black here played Bishop to H3 and
it's uh it's a really and it's a really
nice movie threatens Queen to G2
Checkmate and it doesn't seem like black
uh has anything to worry about if black
really wanted to win this Rook captures
on G3 would be the way to go because now
uh you cannot capture with the F Pawn
you have to capture with the H Pawn that
means Queen captures and G3 also goes
King F1 and now a nice Bishop to H3
check uh simply destroys white for
example Road captures an H3 you're gonna
capture with the queen queen and after
King uh King day two queen to G4 check
now you can also win The Rook or if
white tries to defend this you can play
F3
and uh after Queen the G2 check Bishop
to F2 you can deliver a nice checkmate
with uh Queen captures on F2 uh but in
the game or rather in this famous
composition uh black did not play Rook
captures on G3 or Rook to h8 which is
winning or Bishop to E6 which is winning
but he played Bush of the H3 and it
seems like white is getting checkmated
on the next move but this is one such
composition that teaches us uh not only
that chess is a remarkable game it's a
really a beautiful game but also uh that
you should never give up and that you
always have something to hope for even
in your own games if you're playing
bullet if you're playing Blitz even if
you're playing Rapid or classical it is
possible to achieve such things as they
have been achieved in the past by weaker
and stronger players but now I'm not
gonna tell you what uh how to go about
this position I will tell you that black
does not have to lose this position
black might not win this game but he
most certainly doesn't have to lose it
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find minded the only solution that
allows the black to survive this game
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
those tricky sneaky stalemates and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook captures and d8 and
while you probably thought of this move
because of course you are trying to
postpone Checkmate as much as possible
the next move is the one that really
solves the position for black but uh for
white but how you come
upon such a such a discovery look at
this you cannot move the a pawn you
cannot move the B Pawn you cannot move
the E Pawn you cannot move the f-pawn
you cannot move the H Pawn you cannot
move the Rook you cannot move the king
so the only pieces you can move are the
queen rook and this bishop on E1 so if
you got rid of the queen rook and Bishop
it would be stalemate and that's how you
have to go about this position so Rook
captures an E8 uh once again
congratulations to everyone who found
this King capture Sandy this is the only
move for black and now look at this
spectacular move a queen to D1 with
check this is the animal you had to find
so basically getting rid of the rook and
the Queen and we can't get rid of the
bishop but we can allow the bishop to be
pinned by the queen and here if you
don't capture the White Queen for
example if King to see it just Queen
captures an F3 and now all of a sudden
white is the one who's winning so here
uh black would have to play Queen
captures on D1 and this is now stalemate
a black will not be winning this game
you can't move the pawn you can't move
any of the pawns you cannot move the
king due to the bishop here you cannot
move the Knight due to the rook and the
g file you cannot move the bishop due to
the queen and the back Rank and you
cannot move the F Pawn due to the bishop
on B6 which of course means that this is
now a stalemate so really really a
remarkable position I'm gonna check out
some other ones if uh if uh they're as
nice as this but he is regarded as one
of the greatest end game composers uh
pretty much ever in chess and John Nunn
even tested his uh our Creations the the
uh sort of end games that he created
using table bases just to see if they
were engine precise and he was very very
happy that they were they were
incredibly correct and that uh well Alex
say
alexandritsuke was just a remarkable
composer and or pretty much as I
understand it all of his compositions
were were correct and there were no
errors in making them even though of
course he could not know that at the
time there were no chess engines but now
we can confirm that and well that just
makes uh makes his work uh all the more
uh impressive much like if you would uh
watch a Paul morphe game and use today's
engines you would see that Paul Murphy
was uh truly truly a beast and even if
he played in today's era you know
players would have a lot to worry about
uh but yeah that's the that's the
position I hope you guys enjoyed it and
that uh many of you were able to solve
it if not then I hope you just enjoyed
it and that you you will remember again
you can print screen it you can you know
just print to put it on your
refrigerator or on your bathroom wall or
even in your bathroom so maybe if
someone visits you and goes to the
bathroom they have you know some content
there to enjoy as well uh and uh you
know all in all I hope this improved
your day at least a little bit uh so
yeah that's the position hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Doug and I would like
to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
Andrew Nader srikanta manakashi and Ben
Benjamin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day